en un momento en el que la guerra hace
estragos en europa la gran familia de la
moda ha decidido no cancelar su semana
de la moda del prêt-à-porter de invierno
2022 sin duda los intereses económicos
son demasiado importantes la influencia
cultural de parís y francia no puede
ponerse en peligro la creatividad debe
seguir expresándose
[Música]
la creación es un signo una
manifestación de la vida como la
creación artística y estética
dirían todas las circunstancias la moda
es también un factor esencial en la
emancipación de mujeres y hombres
disonancia cognitiva un espíritu serio y
solemne en un cuerpo ávido de deseo bajo
una gigantesca carpa instalada en el
jardín de las tullerías maria grazia
chiuri para dior ha confeccionado una
colección compleja y exuberante me gustó
mucho la idea de pasar por las épocas y
me fascinaron en los materiales
me encantó el tour me encantaron los
materiales técnicos y me flechó el traje
con el suéter negro y la falda de tul
que era sublime
y las protecciones para motoristas
encanta la chaqueta negra me encanta la
quiero ponerme la en un escenario
diseñado por la artista feminista
italiana mariella betty nets y que nos
invita a echar una nueva mirada a los
retratos de mujeres pintados durante el
renacimiento maria grazia chiuri
reinventa los modelos históricos de la
casa con técnicas innovadoras
desarrolladas por el emprendimiento
italiano tight lab
se suele pensar en la tecnología como
algo abstracto orientado a la
comunicación
y no como algo que pueda ser útil para
la humanidad o cómodo para ella
encontré en este emprendimiento un nuevo
taller
una nueva idea de taller porque trabajan
con patrones como nosotros tienen
máquinas hacen pruebas técnicas y es muy
inspirador
normalmente utilizan sus creaciones para
deportes o experiencias extremas
pero todos estos conocimientos podrían
ser útiles en cualquier lugar de la vida
cotidiana
así que mezcle esta conversación que es
muy experimental con la tradición de la
artesanía en la moda y creo que este
tipo de diálogo podría mejorar la moda
en el futuro
de que
hitcher
el tubo caribeño water también cree que
el futuro debe escribirse hoy los
océanos y su conservación son su
principal fuente de inspiración cuando
no diseñan ropa la pareja trabaja para
preservar los arrecifes de coral su
colección surfea sobre las olas de
colores sublimando las perlas que se
llevan en las islas
nuestra forma de trabajar es expresando
nuestras funciones somos diseñadores más
bien emocionales es como un diario se
trata de expresar lo que sentimos
para expresar y reflejar los tiempos que
vivimos para poner un espejo delante de
la cara de la gente y decir eso es
realmente así
las cosas tienen que cambiar pero como
lo conseguimos cómo es el futuro
y como ser brillantes eso es lo que
mostramos a través de nuestra colección
queremos que la gente imagina el futuro
y para anticipar el futuro que mejor
manera que dar a las nuevas generaciones
herramientas para crearlo el instituto
francés de la moda inauguró esta semana
de la moda de parís con las colecciones
iniciadas por estudiantes una película
que mezcla el mundo real y virtual
hoy escaneamos las siluetas de los 43
diseñadores seleccionamos una silueta
por colección y hacemos escaneos foto
geométricos con 150 a 180 imágenes y
esto se vuelve una escultura es una
primicia mundial
esta escuela líder clasificada en el
primer puesto en gestión de la moda y en
el segundo en diseño de la moda ha
creado un programa totalmente nuevo
esto es natural porque nuestros
estudiantes piensan en términos de la
evolución de las fronteras para ellos el
mundo real y el mundo virtual son
espacios que dan rienda suelta a su
creatividad
así que no los distinguen para ellos
todo este mundo virtual ofrece nuevas
perspectivas y posibilidades creativas
así que no de separación hay una especie
de fluidez
y lo que queríamos mostrar sobre todo
con los accesorios es que los límites de
la creatividad podían llevarse aún más
lejos y sobrepasarse si los poníamos al
servicio y apoyo de una tecnología que
nos permitía crear objetos para este
nuevo mundo virtual llamado metaverso
ningún monitor con el límite a ver
de hecho se trata de trasladar los
rigores del saber real a sus versiones
virtuales es algo un poco inevitable de
hecho hoy en día es realmente parte de
nosotros todos tenemos auriculares
estamos equipados con teléfonos
inteligentes
quiero decir pasamos mucho tiempo en
nuestros correos electrónicos juntos
además con el hobbit se ha acentuado la
importancia de todo eso así que creo que
es algo bastante contemporáneo y por eso
vale la pena analizar y qué relación de
hecho tenemos realmente con todos estos
objetos se está convirtiendo en parte de
la moda cuando siempre usamos
auriculares se está volviendo un poco
más como los aretes en cierto modo se
está convirtiendo en una parte de la
estética me parece muy interesante
esta temporada la semana de la moda de
parís lo ha expresado sin ambigüedades
es gracias a la experimentación por
todos los lados que quizás nazca un
nuevo mundo